- [Instructor] in a previous video,
we introduced this flowchart
that helps us think
about what strategies to use
when trying to determine
a limit of a function
as it approaches a point.
What we're going to do in this video
is now try to apply that in
several example exercises.
So the first question,
they say based on the
process in the flowchart,
let's try to find the limit as
x approaches three of f of x
for f of x is equal to this business.
What are the steps that
we should go through?
And they have these various steps,
and you might say, "Well what
is A and B and C, D and A?"
Well if you go back to
the original flowchart,
you see this is A, this is B,
this is C, this is D,
et cetera, et cetera.
So let's,
let's just first try to substitute,
see if we can get a value for f of three.
If f of three works, then
we are essentially done
because this is not some
strange exotic function,
it seems like it's continuous,
around x equals three,
if f of three exists, let's try it out.
So let me,
so we're going to have f of three
is equal to the square root of,
let's see six minus five,
two times three minus five,
minus one
over three minus three.
So in the numerator here we get zero,
'cause this is one minus one,
so this is going to be
equal to zero over zero.
So the first thing that happens
is we fall into the,
in that we tried to evaluate it,
we fell into indeterminate form.
So the first step is going to be C.
Now the next thing that I would do
because we have a radical expression here,
is to see if I can take a conjugate.
So it's going to likely be,
we're definitely gonna have C first.
Then we're going to try E.
And frankly that's the
only choice that has that,
but let's actually see if
that actually works, CEB.
So let me multiply this
expression times a conjugate.
So the square root of two x minus five,
minus one over x minus three
times the square root of two x minus five
plus one, it's the conjugate here,
over square root of two x
minus five plus one.
And this is going to be
equal to, see this numerator.
The square root of two
x minus five-squared
is going to be two x minus five.
And then you're going to have negative,
you have a minus one-squared
which is going to be minus one.
All of that over x minus three times
the square root of two x minus five,
plus one.
Let's see this stuff up here, this is,
you can rewrite as two x minus six.
Two x minus six,
which is the same thing as
two times x minus three.
And so those cancel out nicely.
And so let's see this
is going to be equal to
two over square root of two x
minus five plus one.
Now let's try to evaluate
this when x equals three.
Well if we do that, we're
going to get two over,
so this is going to be six
minus five, the square root,
which is one plus one.
So it's two over two
which is equal to one.
So then we were able to evaluate it,
and we actually got a value,
so we feel pretty good that we're done.
So we went from finding
indeterminate form,
taking the conjugate and then
being able to evaluate it.
Let me just show that right over here.
When we immediately try to evaluate it,
we got indeterminate form.
We recognize that it was a radical,
that it was a rational
expression with a radical on top.
And so say, let's
multiply by the conjugate.
We did that and then after we were able
to simplify it with the conjugate,
we tried to evaluate it again,
and we were able to get a real number.
So we feel pretty good that
that is going to be the limit.